After being in orbit for almost 28 years,
the Hubble space telescope might be coming
to its end, but does it really have to be?
Hubble is expecting a companion soon known
as the James Webb space telescope.
Hubble’s mission is expected to last into
the 2020s, and the young new James Webb is
expected for launch in 2019.
Which means, for that one year, the two observatories
will be working hand-in-hand in collaborative
data.
But when Hubble comes close to its end, what’s
next?
Hubble has been in space for almost three
decades!
The equipment has been highly exposed to solar
radiation in Lower Earth Orbit...
The fine-guidance sensors, which are some
of the original electronics from the very
start of the mission, are beginning to degrade
due to those high radiation levels...
… Hubble’s had 5 service missions.
AND its camera housing has been hit many times
by space debris--like, it actually has impact
craters.
So, obviously Hubble has been through quite
lot.
And now here comes James Webb..
Which isn’t REPLACING Hubble, but instead,
complementing it.
These observatories are very different from
one another.
Hubble’s images and data are found mainly
in the visible and ultraviolet wavelengths.
Its lead to discoveries like supermassive
black holes being the center of most, if not
all galaxies,
And even confirmed the expansion of the universe...
James Webb, however, will mainly focus on
infrared wavelengths, and because the mirrors
have a six and a quarter (6.25) times more
collecting area than Hubble it will be able
to see way further into the universe than
Hubble ever could.
That’s including seeing galaxies that formed
in the very beginning of our universe!
But still, the main question now, is what
to do with Hubble once its batteries die out
-- which WILL happen, eventually.
We’ve got some options before then: we could
move it into a safe parking orbit somewhere
-- kinda making it into a space museum?
or we could send a mission to Hubble to prepare
it for a guided re-entry and landing to earth.
A lot of scientists feel if we do send a mission
up to Hubble, then why don’t we just refurbish
and keep it in service instead!
But now here it is 2018, and there’s no
solid plan for what to do with this telescope.
If by 2020, we decide to crash land the observatory,
we can control it’s landing by 2028.
But according to NASA’s report on it, the
HST won’t naturally de-orbit before 2027
Otherwise if we just leave it alone, it will
naturally de-orbit itself and crashland somewhere
on Earth.
I don’t know about you guys but I vote for
Hubble being put in service again.
With an ever expanding universe we can use
all the incredible instrumentation that we
have to discover more in our cosmos.
De-orbiting is not a huge deal, there’s
a very low chance it would hit anyone, but
Hubble is really big, how big?
Find out in Trace’s video here!
Remember when Hubble needed fixing after it
launched?
Its optical issues were obviously repaired,
and now this technique they employed is used
today in mammograms to detect breast cancer
months sooner than other methods.